Speaker 1: Lauren Boebert is pleading the
blood of Jesus to try to win her race.
What the hell am I talking about?
I don't even know.
Let me reset the stage.
There are.
There is a triumvirate of MAGA people.
One of whom has already lost.
I'm talking about Marjorie Taylor GREENE,
Madison Cawthorn, Lauren Boebert.
These three are sort of like emblematic.
They are the prototypical whacked out MAGA
candidates that don't have any business being
in the House of Representatives.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE easily won reelection
on Tuesday.
However, Madison Cawthorn lost his Republican
primary months ago and is being removed after
just one term.
Lauren Boebert is number three and indeed
she may lose when we go and take a look at
Colorado and we look at that third district,
you will see that as of this moment.
Adam Frisch, the Democratic challenger, is
64 votes ahead of Lauren Boebert.
That is a razor thin margin.
We don't yet know for sure who will win, but
what we have been told is that the remaining
ballots, that 5% of the vote that is outstanding
favors Adam Fresh and that it is plausible,
while certainly not a guarantee that Lauren
Boebert would be defeated.
Here is something really wacky, and I don't
even know what this means.
Lauren Boebert said that they are pleading
the blood of Jesus to try to win.
This was at the end of her event on Tuesday
night, at which point her confidence level
was a little lower than it was at the start
of the night, that's for sure.
Speaker 2: In the name of Jesus, I thank you
for these people.
They are so precious.
God, we please the blood over our elections.
Father God, I thank you Thursday and your
protection.
I thank you, God, for everything that you
are doing.
Speaker 1: I don't know what it means to plead
the blood of Jesus.
I genuinely don't know what.
Is that a good thing or is it a bad thing?
Speaker 2: Jesus, it doesn't matter who is
in office because you have a team.
Speaker 1: Well, if it doesn't matter, then
I don't even know why Boebert is running.
But that's maybe a question for a different
day.
Is there something wrong with me that I'm
enjoying seeing her potentially lose and just
lose it in this way?
Is that something that I should be exploring
in therapy that I'm taking such pleasure in
her potential misfortune?
Or is it logical, given how horrible and humiliating
a person she is?
Earlier in the night, she was much more confident.
She said it was all trending in her direction.
But judging from the applause, it's not even
really clear the crowd believed it.
Speaker 2: But I am so optimistic.
Yeah, it is absolutely trending in our favor.
As Ben has told you, The New York Times is
still saying Congresswoman Lauren Boebert
is very likely to win.
Speaker 1: Now, the truth is, The New York
Times stopped updating those predictive tools
that they had a few hours into the night,
and it was really worth nothing at that point
in time.
I don't want to celebrate too early because
Lauren Boebert may win, but if indeed some
of the analysts who really know Colorado are
right, who are looking county by county, if
indeed she does lose, it will be a great thing
in all likelihood.
And again, when we look at the numbers, if
we go back from Colorado and we go to the
map right now, you need 218 seats to control
the House of Representatives.
Right now, Democrats have won 91 and Republicans
have 209.
It is still definitely the most likely outcome
that Republicans will control the House.
But controlling it with Lauren Boebert and
Madison Cawthorn both losing their first term
after their first terms is a much better scenario.
And when we consider that triumvirate.
GREENE Cawthorn Boebert removing two thirds
of it is a beautiful thing.
We're going to take a very quick break.
We have a packed program for you today.
The David Pakman Show is an audience supported
program.
I can't tell you how flattered I am at the
nearly 2500 people who got either website
memberships or twitch subscriptions in the
five days leading up to the midterm election.
We did a membership drive during our live
streams.
The goal was initially 1000.
Then we up to 2000.
We up to two 2500 and got to about 20 to 50.
Unbelievable.
And I would love for you to join in.
Get the bonus.
Speaker 3: Show.
The bonus show where you want to make money
and everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Get access to the commercial free
audio and video streams of the show.
Get the invites to the members only town hall
events and so much more.
And do it while supporting independent media.
The coupon code 24 starts now is live and
it's live because 24 has clearly started.
You can sign up at Join Pack.
MEDCOM Let's now talk about 2024.